[موسيقى]
انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
اف 16 فارس لا تستبعد واشنطن ترفض
وبريطانيا تحذر
من رام الله
على حال الدولتين والفلسطينيين يسلمونه
ورقه لبنود
اليه التجنيد في الحرس الثوري الايرانيه
اسباب واضحه ومقنعه ام حجه لعرقله تصنيف
الحرس على قوائم الارهاب
فرنسا اضراب ثامن على مشروع اصلاح قانوني
التقاعد يشل حركه النقل والكهرباء والشرطه
تشتبك مع المحتجين
[موسيقى]
وسعيدهم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
الحرب في اوكرانيا تقترب من اتمام عامها
الاول تطورات الميدانيه تراوحت بين التقدم
والاخفاق على صعيد الجيشين لكن ما هو شبه
ثابت ان الرئيس
فشله في تحقيق اي من اهدافه الرئيسيه التي
خطط لها منذ اليوم الاول بحسب تحليل اجرته
مجله فارس التحليل واشار الى ان بوتن لم
يوحد الامه الواحده المزعومه ولم ينزع
سلاح اوكرانيا ولم يوقف توسع النيته
لسادسه بل تلقت قواته ضربات قاسيه وخسائر
الميدانيه كبيره وفقا للمجله الجيش
الاوكراني في المقابل استطاع ان يلقي
القوات الروسيه خارج العاصمه كيف حتى الان
وادافع عن ثاني اكبر مدينه في اوكرانيا
كما اطلق هجمات المضاده ناجحه في الخريف
حرر بها اكثر من 50% من الاراضي التي
استولى فيها الجنود الروس سابقا
مشاهدينا في ظل كافه التطورات التي تشهدها
الحرب في اوكرانيا لم تشق مفاوضات السلام
طريقها على خط هذا الصراع بعد بل كل
المؤشرات تصب بانها ستكون حربا طويله
الامد سيام وان روسيا تخطط لجنه هجوم واسع
من بعد اشهر قليله او ما اطلق عليه معركه
الربيع فيما يواصل الغرب امداد اوكرانيا
بالدعم العسكري
[موسيقى]
بالحديث عن الدعم العسكري الغربي
المتواصلي لاوكرانيا عدا الجدل الى الساحه
الغربيه وهذه المره ليس على ارسال
الدبابات بالمقاتلات فقد تصاعد الخلاف
الان حول تسليح اوكرانيا من عدمه بطائرات
المقاتله الغربيه
اكثر من مره لكن الاستجابه لهذا الطلب
صعبه وحساسه وسط مخاوف من التورق الغربي
بشكل اعمق في هذه الحرب
على راسي قائمه الدول التي لم تستبعد
ارسال مقاتلات اف 16 الى اوكرانيا كانت
فرنسا حيث قال الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون لا شيء مستبعدا من حيث المبدا لكن
ماكرون شدد ايضا على ان هناك معايير
لاتخاذ اي قرار بهذا الشان وتجنب التصعيد
حيث لا تطول المقاتلات الاراضي الروسيه
بريطانيا كانت اكثر حذرا فقد حذر رئيس
الوزراء ريشي سوناك من ان رساله طائرات
مقاتله لاوكرانيا امر غير عملي في هذه
اللحظه واشنطن كانت اكثر تشددا وحسما حياه
للامر حيث تبدد الرئيس
الامريكيان في الحصول على اف 16 واكد انه
لي يوافق على ارسال الطائرات المقاتله الى
اخرى
نحن على استعداد اللي نظري في الطلبات
الاضافيه من الاوكرانيين مع ضمان احترام
المبادئ الثلاثه اولا يجب الا تؤدي
مساعدتنا الى تصعيد للنزاع ثانيا يجب ان
تكون مفيده وفعاله بسرعه واخيرا يجب ان لا
تضعف قدراتنا الدفاعيه
العربيه
مرحبا بكم جميعا بيير ابدا معك لا مقاتلات
اف 16
لاوكرانيا فما الذي سيقدمه الامريكيون
ايضا
الرئيس الامريكيه قال انه سوف يتحدث الى
الرئيس الاوكراني عن المساعدات العسكريه
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض على الطائره
الرئاسيه قالت ان هناك حزمه جديده من
المساعدات العسكريه التي سترسلها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الى اوكرانيا عمليا
الان يشبه الى حد كبير المفاوضات العالميه
حول ارسال الدبابات الى الاوكرانيه نعم
ااه ريما في لندن حضر اكثر فيما يتعلق
خاصه بارسال مقاتله الاف 16 للاوكرانيين
همم ما الذي تخشاه بريطانيا
وقالت بريطانيا صهيب لن يكون هناك
لاتايفون ولا مقاتلات الافتر تي 5 اف 35
لاوكرانيا بحسب الحجه الرسميه التي شرحها
ااا شرحتها رئاسه الحكومه مكتب تن داونز
ستريت ان هذه الاسلحه متطوره جدا
فتاكه جدا سوف استيكيتد هي الكلمه التي
استخدمتها يعني متطوره وتحتاج لاشهر من
التدريب ولهذا سمعنا من رئيس الحكومه ريشي
سونا كلمات هذا هذه خطه ليست عمليا اي اي
معنى ذلك انه سيكون على بريطانيا ان ترسل
فريق من الجيش ومن المدربين لاوكرانيا
لتدرب التيارين لمده اشهر وليس اليوم او
اليومين هذا هو اقل له السبب الرسمي
والعلني الى موسكو عبد الجواد اوكرانيا
بدات بالفعل قالت انها ستتسلم على الاقل
140 دبابه من ما وعدت به والان الحديث عن
مفاوضات بش المقاتلات همم كذلك ما الذي
ستفعله موسكو التي توعدت سابقا باستهداف
الاسلحه الغربيه التي ستصل الى اوكرانيا
مساء الخير صهيب لك ولزملاء نعم في
الحقيقه
هي خطوه بعض الدول الغربيه وهنا تحدث عن
دول البلطيق وبولندا بتزويد كيف في
المقاتلات بالعدوان للغايه كما وصفته وان
هذه الخطوه لاحمد اباها طبعا موسكو ترى في
هذا الموقف بانه خطوه فقط لمده الصراع هو
الازمه من جهه وانه لن يؤثر على سير
الاحداث بغض النظر عن اننا التصعيد سيرتفع
بشكل كبير على جانب الاخر ما زلت موسكو
تتحدث بانها تسيطر بشكل كلي على كافه
الاجواء اوكرانيه وان هذه الخطوه ودخول
هذه المقاتلات ستهدف من قبل الجانب الروسي
وستتحطم كما ترى وزاره الدفاع الى باريس
حسين قنيبر
بالنسبه لباريس لا شيئا مستبعدا بالنسبه
لتسليم الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا ولكن يجب ان
يكون هناك معايير ما الذي يعني ذلك
نعم اهلا بك الصهيب اكرر وزير الدفاع
الفرنسي خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك بعد ظهور
اليوم مع نظيره الاوكراني اوليكس سيريس
ديكوف التفكير بهذه المعايير التي كان
ذكرها الرئيس الفرنسي مكرون امس هذه
المعايير هي ثلاثه اولا الا يكون هدف
استخدام المعدات العسكريه التي ترسل الى
اوكرانيا مهما كان نوعها لغايات هجوميه بل
فقط لغايات دفاعيه ولتمكين اوكرانيا بل
لتعزيز جهدها في المقاومه وحمايه اراضيها
ثانيا يجب ان يكون ما يرسل الى اوكرانيا
مفيدا وذلك من خلال تدريب وتكوين الجنود
الاكرانيين على
استخدام هذه المعدات وعلى صيهنتها اذا
تعطلت ثالثا المعيار الثالث هو يجب الا
يؤثر ارسال المعدات العسكريه الى اوكرانيا
على المعدات على القدرات الدفاعيه للجيش
الفرنسي لانه كما تعلم المخزون العسكري
لفرنسا كان بعد الحرب البارده وخصوصا بعد
العام 2007 بدات تفكك وتبيع بعضا من
مخزونها العسكري لتجنب نفقات صيانته وهذا
واحد من الاسباب التي تجعلها تتردد في
ارسال الدبابات لوبلير الثقيله مثلا الى
اوكرانيا لان سعر الدبابه الواحده يبلغ
ثمانيه ملايين يورو ونفقت صيانه كل دبابه
سنويه تبلغ ربع مليون يورو هذا واحد من
الاسباب وزير الدفاع الفرنسي قال ان هناك
شمعه نظيره الاوكراني اليوم اولا كيفيه
تعزيز اعمال الصيانه للمعدات التي ترسل
وثانيا تعزيز تدريب وتاهيل الجنود
الاكرانيين الهدف هو ان تتمكن فرنسا من
تاهيل 600 جندي اوكراني شهريا وفي خطوه
الاولى تاهيل وتكوين الفي جندي من الان
وحتى حلول الصيف المقبل مع الاعلان عن
تقديم اثني عشر مدفع سيزار اضافيه
بالاضافه الى ما كان ارسل الى من هذه
المدافع
سابقا صهيب الى واشنطن اعود اليك بيير
ذكرت قبل قليل انه المفاوضات على ما يبدو
انه بالنسبه للمقاتلات هي نفسها ما حدث في
موضوع الدبابات المؤشرات والتقييمات تتحدث
عن معركه الربيع ان بوتين يسعى الاقتحام
هذه المره هل هذا هو المعيار الذي يمكن ان
تغير واشنطن بسببه سياسه التسليح
لاوكرانيا وتمدها بالاسلحه الهجوميه التي
يمكن ان تطال الاراضي روسيا ام هذا مستبعد
بتاتا
هذا مستبعد ما يعمل عليه العسكريون
الامريكيون مع الاوكرانيين هو التاكد من
انها الروس لن يتمكنوا من شن هجوم ويحتلوا
مساحات اضافيه من اوكرانيا بل ان اعطاء
الدبابات سوف يعطي الاوكرانيين الامكانيه
للدفاع وايضا لخلق الدفاعات الروسيه
وتحرير اراضي احتلتها القوات الروسيه خلال
الاشهر الماضيه مساله توسيع الحرب ليست
مطروحه لدى الامريكيين مساله تحرير
الاراضي مطروحه لدى الامريكيين والرزم
المقبله من التسليح الامريكي للاوكرانيين
سوف تركز ايضا على ذلك نعم ريما في لندن
اعود اليك ماذا عن التقييم البريطاني
لمسار هذه الحرب
والمخاوف مما بات يصطلح عليه بمعركه
الربيع المنتظره التي تحشد لها روسيا
تريد بريطانيا ان تجهز اوكرانيا بشتى
الطرق تساعدها في الاستخبارات بعدد كبير
من الاسلحه تشالنجر
نظام
صاروخي مهم جدا دفاعي الكثير من الاسلحه
ولكن بريطانيا تاخذ في الحسبان موضوع
الحرب الوكاله في اي وقت تشعر روسيا انها
حرب تدخل فيها بريطانيا وباقي دول اوروبيه
واربما امريكا بشكل مباشر وان ااه عبر
ربما تزويد عدد من الاسلحه غير مسموح به
او غير متفق عليه بصوره غير على نيه فهذا
يغير معادله القتال وهذا ما تقلق منه
بريطانيا ايضا وبشكل سريع بريطانيا لديها
مشاكلها الداخليه الميزانيه دفاعيه مهمه
جدا بالنسبه للبريطانيين هناك تقارير من
يومين كانت يعني مهمه جدا بان الجيش
البريطاني يحتاج الكثير من التسليح يحتاج
الكثير من المدنيزيشن اي لا تحديد نعم
وبالتالي وبالتالي على بريطانيا ان تجهز
جيشها بشكل اولي يكون جاهز لاي هجوم محتمل
هذه مخاوف بريطانيا
العربيه اذن من باريس لندن موسكو واشنطن
حسين
المقاتلات لم يوقف استمرار التدفق الدعم
العسكري الغربي
الامريكيه الاوروبيه الاخيره بارسال
الدبابات حيث اعلن وزير الدفاع النرويجيه
ستنقل 2 الالمانيه الى اوكرانيا نهايتها
مارس القادمه في ما لم يحدد الوزير
النرويجي عددها الى ان بلاده تملك 36
دبابه من طراز لهيفار 2 وكانت المانيا
اعلنت انها ستسمح للدول الاخرى التي تمتلك
هذه الدبابات الالمانيه لنقلها الى
اوكرانيا
هذا في ما اعلن وزير الخارجيه في
الاوكرانيه دي متر كوليبا ان كيف حصلت على
تعهدات بتلقي 120 الى 140 دبابه في الدفعه
الاولى من المساعدات الغربيه
ستتلقى القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بين 120
و140 دبابه غربيه حديثه هي اليوبارد اثنان
كما نعول كثيرا على دبابات هذا ليس عددا
صغيرا لكننا نواصل العمل على توسيع ائتلاف
الدبابات وزياده الدعم من الحلفاء
[موسيقى]
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاوكرانيه دينيس شميغل
عن عقد قمه بين اوكرانيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي في كيف الجمعه الاوضحه ان القمه
ستكون غداه مشاورات حكوميه بين اوكرانيا
والمفوضيه الاوروبيه وستكون الاولى في
تاريخ كيف وقال الرئيس الوزراء الاوكرانيه
خلال الاجتماع الحكوميا ان عقد هذه القمه
في كياب يوجه رساله قويه الى الشركاء
والاعداء على احد سواء بحسب تعبيره وقال
كذلك انه يتوقع من القمه تقيما المرحاليا
ايجابيا لجهود اوكرانيا لتحقيق التكامل مع
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
وعلى صعيد التطورات الميدانيه في الحرب
تغيرات لافته تشهدها الجبهه الشرقيه في
اوكرانيا روسيا طورت على مدى ثلاثه ايام
الماضيه هجماتها حول بلدتي بابليكا وفلدار
بشرق اوكرانيا في هجوم الوصفه باكثر
احكاما على هذه المنطقه بحسب وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه احتمال كبير توقعه محللون بان
تواصل روسيا تحقيق مكاسبه في هذا القطاع
لكن استبعاد امتلاكها لعدد كافي من القوات
لتحقيق اختراق كبير في جبهه القتال فيما
تسعى القياده الروسيه الى تطوير المحور
الجديد للتقدم في دمياط الواقعه تحت سيطره
اوكرانيا وتحويل قوه الاوكرانيه عن القطاع
بخمط الذي تدور حوله معارك شرسه
اذا نعرف المزيد حول التطورات الميدانيه
من دونيتك معنا مراسلنا رائد الاخبار رائد
اهلا بك معنا تقدم روسي واضحه على الجبهه
الشرقيه اخر التطورات الميدانيه عندك
صهيب بالفعل يعني الفتره الاخيره شهدت
تقدما روسيا على مستوى المعارك في جميع
المحاور الجنوبيه والشماليه والتقارير
البريطانيه التي تحدثت اظن عن افضيفك وليس
افديك ممكن ان يكون الاسم باللغه
الاوكرانيه مدينه تشهد عمليات اقتحام
متكرره كل يوم لكن حتى الان لم تستطع
القوات الروسيه الدخول الى المدينه بينما
همم تقول السلطات هنا عن مدينه اوبلدار ان
حاولت اقتحامها من عده نواحي الجنوبيه
والشرقيه لكن القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
صامده بسبب ال يعني الالات العسكريه
الثقيله والدبابات ويعني حصون المنيعه
التي تتمتع فيها اطراف المنطقه حسب نائب
القائم باعمال الجمهوريه هنا بالفعل
القوات الروسيه تتقدم ايضا في المحور
الشمالي نحو باء متوسطه
الاوكرانيه كانت ابدت فيما سبق يعني صمودا
اقوى وكانت حتى تقدمت في بعض المحاور فالى
ما يرجع هذا التقدم الروسي الان
طبعا منذ بدايه العام اعلنت موسكو عن دخول
عديد من الاسلحه المتطوره في نطاق العمليه
العسكريه منها مقاتلات ومنها صواريخ ومنها
ايضا دبابات حديثه ربما انا لهذا كان اثر
كبير اضافه الى نقص الذخيره عند الجانب
الاوكراني يعني بالفعل المدينه هنا داني
تشهد انخفاضا كبيرا بكثيره القسم
الاوكراني على المدينه ذلك لان القوات
الروسيه دفعت الجيش الاوكراني للابتعاد
ااه قليلا ربما عن دخول مدينه اذني قربما
لنقص الدقيقه حسب تصريحات الدفاع بانها
تدمر مستودعات الذخيره لدى القران جزيلا
[موسيقى]
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه موجه كورونا في
الصين تقترب من نهايتها والبلاد وصلت
لمناعه قطيع مؤقته
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في خضم التوترات التي
شهدتها الاراضي الفلسطينيه واسرائيل في
الايام القليله الماضيه جاءت زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه الى الشرق الاوسط
حامله معها ملفات عديده على راسها ايجاد
حلول لخفض هذه التوترات لكن اكد على ضروره
اتخاذ اجراءات سريعه وفوريه لتخفيف حده
التوتر بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
وقال ان واشنطن تعارض اي خطوات تقوض حل
الدولتين كهدم البيوت وانشاء المستوطنات
الولايات المتحده عازمه على العمل مع
شركائها لتعزيز بيئه اكثر استقرارا وايجاد
حلول وسطى للخروج من دوامه العنف واستئناف
محادثه السلام بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وطالبنا كافه الاطراف بخفض
التصعيد
حذر خلال المؤتمر الصحفي من ان الولايات
المتحده لن تقبل باي خطوات احاديه قد تجعل
من مساله حل الدولتين
ان اعقد مما هي عليه الان
كنا واضحين ومتسقين في قناعتنا بانه لا
ينبغي لاي من الطرفين اتخاذ اي اجراءات
احاديه جانب الان من المحتمل ان تصب الزيت
على النار على مدى فتره طويله من الزمن
الى ابعد مما هو عليه اليوم
اما الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس فحمل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه التصعيد في
الفتره الاخيره لعدم التزامها بحل
الدولتين مشددا على ان الوقف الكامل
للاعمال الاسرائيليه الاحذيه الجانب هو
المدخل الاساسي لعوده الافق السياسيه
ونؤكد لكم لان ما يحدث هذه الايام
تتحمل مسؤوليته الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بسبب ممارساتها التي تقود حلا الدولتين
وتخالف الاتفاقات الواقعه
وبسبب عدم نزول الدوليه
[موسيقى]
الاستيطان
وعدم الاعتراف بالدوري الفلسطيني
هذا وسلمت القياده الفلسطينيه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه ورقه من 12 بندا تخص
الاجراءات احاديه الجانب التي تقوم بها
اسرائيل وقضايا الوضع نهائي بحسب مصادر
العربيه وطالب الفلسطينيون الاداره
الامريكيه بالضغط على اسرائيل للالتزام
بهذه البنود كشرط لاعاده التنسيق مع
اسرائيل وعوده الهدوء تمهيدا لاي مفاوضات
محتمله
توج وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
سلسله الزيارات الامريكيه الى رام الله
هذا الشهر بداها مستشار الامن القومي ثم
مديره وكاله الاستخبارات السياسيه
من الفلسطينيين هو التهدئه والثمن وعد
بالحفاظ على مبدا حل الدولتين واعاده فتح
القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه و50
مليون دولار الى جانب توفير خدمه الجيل
الرابع للانترنت وغيرها
في هذه الاثناء نحن نعرض اي اجراء من جانب
اي طرف لجعل لحل الدولتين صعب المنال ونحن
كنا واضحين ان هذا يشمل اجراءات كتوسيع
المستوطنات وتشريع البؤري الاستيطانيه
واعمال هدم البيوت واخلاء المنازل من
سكانها وتغيير الوضع القائم التاريخي في
الاماكن المقدسه
الوعود والزيارات الامريكيه ل رام الله
تبدو مرضيه نوعا مال السلطه الفلسطينيه
بعد قطيعه اداره ترامب لكن ليست كافيه
فيرىى الفلسطينيون ضروره ان تترجم الى
خطوات عمليه على الارض لعوده المسار
التفاوضي لذلك سلموا لاداره الامريكيه
ورقه من 12 بندا ابرزها ان تتوقف اسرائيل
عن اقتحام المدن وتوسيع المستوطنات وتغيير
الوضع التاريخي والديني في القدس
للعمل مع الاداره الامريكيه
في المجتمع الدولي لعوده الحوار السياسي
من اجل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
عمليات من جانب الاداره الامريكيه لتنفيذ
ايلتزام من هذه الالتزامات منذ تسلم هذه
الاداره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه طلب من
القياده الفلسطينيه اعاده التنسيق الامني
مع اسرائيل والحد من انتشار المجموعات
المسلحه وبسط السيطره الامنيه والمضيء
بالاصلاحات القانونيه
للمنطقه ستظهر بعد انتهائها مباشره ان
كانت اسرائيل ستوقف اقتحامات المدن وبناء
المستوطنات وهدم المنازل ام ان وزراء
حكومه نتنياهو من اليمين المتطرف سيواصلون
مغامره تكون نتائجها دمويه كما حدث في
الشهر الاول من هذا العام عبد الحفيظ
جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه من رام
الله ينضم الينا الباحث في شان الاسرائيلي
عصمت منصور استاذ عصمه اهلا بك معنا في
اخبار الساعه هل نجح بلينكن في تخفيف
التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
مساء الخير وتحياتي لكم ولي المتابعات
والمتابعين يعني واضح انه لينكن منذ
البدايه ومع وصوله الى اسرائيل وضع اهداف
متواضعه
لزيارته وهو تحدث عن ضمان الهدوء واستمرار
هذا الهدوء وايضا ان لا يكون هناك يعني
اتخاذ خطوات احاديه من الجانب الاسرائيلي
تقضي نهائيا على حل الدوالتين واعتقد انه
هذه اهداف نسريا استطاع ان يحقق يعني
انجازات فيها علما انها اهداف متواضعه كما
كنا في البدايه هو يعني واضح انه من خلال
هذه الجوله وايضا الجهود التي رايناها
اقليميه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه بتركبتها
الحاليه التي تقدم على تصرفات احاديه
الجانب اكثر ربما من من سابقاتها هل
ستستجيب للضغط للضغط الامريكي لهذا الطلب
الامريكي الفلسطيني سلموا همم 12 بندا من
اجل همم تخفيف التوتر هل تعتقد ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه ستستجيب للضغط
الامريكي
يعني هذا هو امتحان ثاني ياهو اولا امتحان
لمده جديته وهو يعني بدنا ان يكون دائما
يعني يمارس التضليل والخداع والمناورات
وايضا امتحان لقدرته على ضبط هذه الحكومه
ولاجمها والامساك بخيوطها كما تعهد ل- همم
الحلفاء الغربيين الولايات المتحده لذلك
هذا يعتقد انه يعني هذا سيتضح خلال الفتره
القادمه في قضايا هناك قضايا سيلتزم بها
مثلا وضعت الولايات المتحده خطوط حمراء
وبعض من القضايا التي ستقضي كليا على حاله
الدولفين هذه اعتقد ستلزمه الولايات
المتحده بها اما البناء الاستعطاني بشكل
عام وفي المناطق والهدم هذه انا اشك ان
يستطيع يعني تنفيذ هذه لذلك يعني واضح انه
الهدوء سيستقرام لفتره قصيره الى ان يعني
ناتي لموجه جديد
موجه جديده من للتصعيد في الافق طيب ولكن
حديث بلنكن على تمسك واشنطن بمساله حل
الدولتين هل هذا في حال ذاته مؤشر ايجابي
ام هذا يبقى فقط في اطار البروتوكول
الشعارات الدبلوماسيه بين هلالين للاداره
الامريكيه
طبعا غير كافي هذا
غير الامريكيه ولكن كنا نتوقع ان تتخذ
خطوات لتعزيز هذا الحل لاعطائه يعني
امكانيه ان يبقى على قيد الامل كما يقولون
في الحكومه السابقه تجنبت طرح هذا الموضوع
لاداره الامريكيه واتخاذ اي خطوه خشيه على
الحكومه الهشه التي كان يقودها لبيد كي لا
تنهار والان يؤجلون هذا الموضوع ويكونون
نحن معه ولكن لن نسعى لتطبيقه الان وان
الظرف غير مؤتي وعلى الارض اسرائيل تقضي
على هذا حلب لذلك هذا غير مرضي وغير كافي
يعني كنا نامل ان تقدم مبادره سياسيه مثلا
ان تقدم ان تلزم اسرائيل بالاعتراف ولو
نظريا بهذا الحل ان تلاجه ولو ان ينطق
لفظيا هذا الحل ولكن للاسف حتى هذا غير
موجود
عصمت منصور البحث في شان الاسرائيلي من
رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اك
د مره اليين اثنين جراء احاديثي دهس شمالي
الضفه الغربيه ووقع حادث الدهس عند حاجز
زعتر شمالي الضفه فيما قالت مصادر عسكريه
اسرائيليه ان العمليه قد تكون مقصوده حيث
غادر سائق السياره مسرعا بعد الحادث
[موسيقى]
في الوقت الذي تنظر فيه الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي والمملكه المتحده في
ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني كمنظمه
ارهابيه كشفت مجله فرن بوليسيه عن اصوات
تعارض هذا التصنيف متحججتا بمجموعه من
الاسباب ابرزها ان الحرس الثوري الايراني
يضم مجموعات من المجندين يتم اختيارهم
بشكل عشوائي ويتم تجنيدهم بالقوه
اسقاط الطائره الاوكرانيه
محاوله اغتيال
بمنزلها في الولايات المتحده تهديدات
بتصفيه المعارضين الايرانيين في بريطانيا
القتال في سوريا الى جانب النظام
احداث اشارت فيها اصابع الاتهام الى الحرس
الثوري الايراني الدعوات تنامه مطالبه
بحظر الحرس الثوري الايراني واعتباره
منظمه ارهابيه
من الاسباب ابرزها ان الحرس الثوري
الايرانيه يضم مجموعات من المجندين يتم
اختيارهم بشكل عشوائي وبالقوه وان هؤلاء
الى خيار لهم سواء اكمال الخدمه الاجباريه
بوليسيه
لعرقله تصنيف الحرس ارهابيا رغم ان اسباب
التصنيف واضحه ومقنعه وان هذه الحجه تستند
الى فهم خاطئ لاليه التجنيد والصياغه التي
يستخدمها الحرس الثوري الايراني مؤكده ان
المجندين لفتره مؤقته يحصلون على بطاقه
نهايه الخدمه الاجباريه على عكس اعضاء
الحرس ومن بين 400,000 ايراني يتم قلبهم
للخدمه العسكريه في البلاد هناك فقط
50,000 ينضمون سنويا للحرس الثوري وهؤلاء
يتم تدريبهم على العمل المليشيوي كما
يخضعون للتلقين العقائدي هم وعائلتهم ايضا
وبحسب فرن بوليسي فان التلقين
الايديولوجيه ركيزه اساسيه لعمل الحرس حيث
يمثل التطرف اكثر من 50% من التدريب في
الحرس الثوري الايراني اليوم
بلال البوجدين العربي
من امستردام ينضم الينا فؤاد عطيه بحث في
شان الايرانيه استاذ فؤاد اهلا بكم معنا
في اخبار الساعه من العربيه ما رايك في
هذه الحجه القائله بانه لا يجب تصنيف
الحرس الثوري الايراني على لائحه المنظمات
الارهابيه لان
اعضائه المنتمين للحرس الثوري هم مجندون
بالقوه ضد رغبتهم وبشكل عشوائي
اعتقد كما اكد تقريركم انه مجرد حجه لوقفه
تصنيفه يمكن منظمه ارهابيه همم
جزء من هذه الحجه قد يكون صحيح لان
التجنيد في الحرس الثوري او التجنيد في
ايران بشكل عام هو اجبار الجانب اجباري من
هناك همم اثنين
الجانب الكادر والجانب الاجباري الجانب
الاجباري الجندي لا يختار وليس لديه حقا
يعترف بالتجنيد يجب ان يخضع لامر الدوله
بالتجديد مثلا في الحرس الثوري او في
الجيش او في الشرطه ولكن انها حجه لان
الحركه بشكل عام يمكن ان يتلاعب
بوسائق التجنيد مثلا هو الان همم العمليه
الارهابيه التي همم
اوقفتها اوروبا اخيرا ضد المعارضه استخدم
الحرس الثوري همم
وثائق الدبلوماسيين لتنفيذ العمليه اه
المشكله هنا انه يمكن الثقه بنظام
الايراني بشكل عام والحركه الثوري كالجهاز
ولكن سوف
مما يتضح من الموقف الاوروبي انه هناك
رغبه في تصنيف الحرس الثوري كمنظمه
ارهابيه ولكن الاليه القانونيه الاوروبيه
معقده يجب ان يكون هناك مسار قضائي ويكون
هناك حكم قضائي يثبت تورط الحرس الثوري في
قضيه ارهابيه في اوروبا هل هذا هو الواقع
ام انه فعلا هناك جناح اوروبي يرفض همم
هذا التصنيف
المشكله هناك حتى الجانب بالقضاء هناك
السجل كبير بعمليات ارهابيه
في في اوروبا خلال 30 سنه ضد المعارضين ضد
المجموعات ثانيه حتى القضاء رغم انه
الموضوع هنا وهمم مستقل ولكن ليس متفق على
على صياغه تصنيف هذا همم تصنيف هذه
المنظمه المشكله انهم لا يريدون اعتقد هي
اكثر مشكله سياسيه اكثر من ومجرد قضائي
هنا السؤال لماذا لا تريد اوروبا تصنيف
الحرس الثوري على قوائم الارهاب في هذه
الحلقه اعتقد بجزء كبير من ال ال
الاوروبيين ما زالوا همم
متمسكين بالرؤيه الخياليه للتصالح مع
النظام او يمكن
اعاده التفاوض هذه النظره التقليديه التي
تتبنوها منذ يمكن يمكن 40 سنه او 50 سنه
من بدايه الوجود النظام مع النظام
الايراني ومع انظمه شموليه اخرى ولكن فشلت
الان يعني حتى الذين كانوا يدعمون هذه هذه
السياسه
غالبا الاحزاب اليساريه او الاشتراكيه
الديمقراطيه الان هي بسبب الثوره الحاليه
في ايران بسبب مطار المدنيه الان هي ضد
همم اي نوع تصالح مع ايران يعني عمليا
ضد صالح ولكن الجانب الدولي لا يريدون ان
يوصفوا ضمن سياسات محافظه او قريبه من
سياسات ترامب او المحافظين الاحزاب
المحافظه نعم اعتقد هذا اكثر مشكله من انه
كونها هل هي منظمه ارهابيه ام لا هذا هو
السؤال الحقيقي الذي
يمكن ان يخشوا الاجابه عليه شكرا جزيلا لك
فؤاد عطيه انت الباحث الشجره الايراني كنت
معنا من امستردام
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى فرنسا الان والا للمره الثانيه
في شهر واحد خرجت تظاهرات في انحاء البلاد
احتجاجا على مشروع قرار الحكومي اقترحه
الرئيس ايمن والماكرون لرفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما عوضا عن 62 على احتجاجات
والاضرابات التي شارك فيها مئات الالاف
تسببت بشل عده قطاعات كان نقل العموميه
المدارس وانتاج الكهرباء والمصافي النفطيه
ووسائل الاعلام الحكوميه
هذا ودعت النقابات العماليه الفرنسيه
لمزيد من الاحتجاجات في السابع والحادي
عشر من فبراير المقبل ضد قانون التقاعد
الجديد فيما تضاربت احصائيات المشاركين في
تظاهرات اليوم حيث كانت وزاره الداخليه
الفرنسيه ان مليون 270 الف متظاهر شارك
فيها فيما اوضحت النقابات العماليه ان
مليونين و800,000 شاركوا في احتجاجات
اليوم ضد قانون التقاعد
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الصين ان العاصمه بكين وصلت الى
مناعه قطيع مؤقتا من فيروس كورونا وان
تفشي كورونا اقترب من نهايته وقالت
السلطاته ان العدد اليومي لوفيات كورونا
في البلاد تراجع الاسبوع الماضي بنسبه 80
في المئه مقارنه بعد بدايه الشهر اعتبرت
الصين ان خطرا انتقال العدوى انخفض نسبيا
حيث يتم تسجيله فقط حالات متفرقه من
الاصابه بالبر
[موسيقى]
كشف الادعاء العام في المانيا عن تفاصيل
صادمه لجريمه هزه الشارع شهر اغسطس الماضي
فيما تواجه فتاه المانيه من اصل عراقي
تهمه القتل العمد بعد ان استدرجت فتاه لها
ملامح تشبه ملامحها وقتلتها بعشرات
الطعنات من اجل تلفيق خبر وفاتها تابعه
[موسيقى]
قتلت فتاه تشبهها لتلفق خبر وفاتها
جريمه هزت الشارع الالماني في اغسطس
الماضي لكن الادعاء العام كشفت تفاصيل
صادمه 2022
غادرت شربان فتاه المانيه من اصول عراقيه
منزلها ولم تعد اليه ما اثار قلق ذويها
وبعد عمليات البحث مع الشرطه عن المفقوده
عثر على سيارتها وبداخلها جثه بلا معالم
اعتقدوا انها للفتاه المفقوده
لكن الصدمه جاءت في اليوم التالي بعد
تحليلات الحمض النووي تبين ان الجثه تعود
لفتاه اخرى واسمها خديجه تشبه كثيرا
الفتاه المفقوده التي عثرت الشرطه عليها
لاحقا واحتجزتها على ذمه التحقيق
وفق الشرطه فان المتهمه رتبت وفاتها
المزوره وقررت الاختفاء بسبب مشاكل عائليه
من النساء اللواتي يشبهنها عبر تطبيق
انستغرام
تواصلت المتهمه عدد من الفتيات اللواتي
كانت لديهن ملامح تشبهها وقع لاختيار على
فتاه ذات اصول عربيه عمرها 23 عاما
اقنعتها بضروره لقائهما مقابله وعودا
زائفه لم توضح الشرطه تفاصيلها
بعد اللقاء
استدرجت المتهمه وصديق اخر لها الضحيه الى
غابه
وطعناها عشرات المرات بهدف تلفيقي خبر
وفاتها
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه تويتر يسدد جزءا
من ديونه
لكن الفاتوره لا تزال كبير
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في ظل سعيه
ترسنتها النوويه والتزود بصوارخ جديده
وللمره الثالثه بصفته وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
بين البلدين ومناقشه التحديات الامنيه اكد
ايضا ان الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
ستجريان تدريبات النظريه لتعزيز ضد
التهديدات النوويه
[موسيقى]
والى جانب التدريبات النظريه مع كوريا
الجنوبيه وزير الدفاع الامريكي لود اوستن
وخلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع نظيره الكوري
الجنوبي في سول اكد ان الولايات المتحده
ملتزمه باستخدام الاسلحه التقليديه
والنوويه للردع والادفاع عن كوريا
الجنوبيه هذا بيان المشترك بان لويد اوستن
ونظيره الكوري الجنوبي ليونصف تعهدا
بتوسيع مستوى ونطاق التدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه بين البلدين
[موسيقى]
ايبدو ان ملف عملاق التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر لا يغيب عن عناوين الاخبار
الاسبوعيه فبعد ازمه الاستقالات والاقالات
التي عصفت بالعصفور الازرق ظهرت منذ فتره
قضيه الديون المترتبه على الشركه لكن
تويتر سددت اول دفعه فائده على ديون بقيمه
12.5 مليار دولار استخدمها الى الماسك
لجعل عملاق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي شركه
خاصه العام الماضي حيث استعانه الشركه
بمجموعه من سبعه بنوك بقياده الذي علق
الديون او علقه بالديون بعد ان عجز عن
بيعها لمستثمرين خارجين رغم ذلك مشاهدينا
يبدو ان فاتوره الديون بالنسبه لتويتر لا
تزال كبيره حيث من المتوقع ان تتجاوز
الفائده السنويه 1.2 مليار دولار ويحمل
بعضها معدلات متغيره من الفائده يمكن ان
تستمر في الزياده مع قيام الاحتياطيه
الفيدراليه الامريكيه برفع اسعارها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخباره ساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرزها
الغرب يسرع تهيئه الاوكرانيين لاستقبال
اليوبارد ويختلف على ارسال اف 16 فبس
توافق واشنطن ترفض وبريطانيا تحذر
من رام الله بلنكن يؤكد اللامسامه على حال
الدولتين والفلسطينيين يسلمونه ورقه لبنود
التهدئه
اليه التجنيد في الحرس الثوري الايرانيه
اسباب واضحه ومقنعه ام حجه لعرقله تصنيف
الحرس على قوائم الارهاب
فرنسا اضراب ثاني على مشروع اصلاح قانون
التقاعد يشل حركه النقل والكهرباء والشرطه
تشتبك مع المحتاجين
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
على العربيه
[موسيقى]